and what about this dude
this is so sad Titanic tourists
submerged Titanic tourist submersible
goes missing with search underway here's
the thing about the Titanic if the
[__] Titanic couldn't do it
you know either you [__] five Rich
[__] are gonna be able to no my
heart goes out to him seriously I don't
mean to say [__] but a massive
search and rescue operation is underway
dude this is just so awful when you're
like
they got to be like we got to go get the
we got to go search and rescue and
they're like we know
they're underwater they don't have okay
let's go it's so sad dude contact uh
massive search and rescue operation is
underway at the Mid-Atlantic after
imagine trying to find something in the
ocean dude you ever drop something
straight up like while you're sitting in
a chair where'd it go
it rolled where'd it go I didn't drop it
where it is how did that happen
it's so far whenever you drop some they
think they're gonna find this little
thing in the
tickets cost 250 thousand dollars for an
eight day trip including Dives to the
wreck at a depth of
wow this is horrible dude
um Ocean Gate is the is the tour firm
oh god dude they're done huh
Titanic's wreck lies some 435 miles
south of
and they wanted to look for it these
rich people
58 year old British billionaire is among
them
damn
on social media proud to finally
announce that he would be aboard the
mission to
see the wreck of the Titanic
um
but because of the worst winner in
Newfoundland Newfoundland in 40 years
this mission is likely to be the first
and only man mission to the Titanic in
2023 this is the thing man that's like
that [__]
God don't go if it's like well we can
but
look he later wrote a weather window has
opened and up and we're going to attempt
to dive tomorrow see
now man who dude you're going underwater
you're not going to the it's not like
well there's a lot of traffic
dude you're going to see you're
literally going to see a failure
and you're doing the thing that they
failed at
look at this guy wanton good soup
tweeted I'm gonna keep it real this is
the most dead anyone has ever been
because they I know they got to keep
hope alive I know God Twitter's just
[__] awful you know like families are
grieving or like so sad and worried and
then good soup goofball or whatever the
[__] his name is it's just like I'm
Gonna Keep It Real I'm Gonna Keep it a
bean they died
um
look at this thing look how small and
cramped it is dude they didn't even die
comfortable too
so sad
they're so far from I mean dude
this is so sad
not to end on a good note but
how about our Chris
how about how crazy that the [__]
Titanic is that's still look at that
that's still what a recently released
video showing a 3D video view of Titanic
shipwreck wow there it is huh
doesn't even really look that bad
honestly
all right
look at that wow
oh this is not the real thing though
this is a 3D render I guess we can't see
under all that [__] maybe
how do they know that that's what it
looks like I don't like 3D renderings
they're not true man that's crazy crazy
crazy
[Music]
congratulations